this video was made in collaboration
with telecom once upon a time there was
a brave Swedish man called PewDiePie
forty pine was an enthusiastic sailor
enough the ocean like he not a stupid
dog Edgar alright alright let's get
serious for a lob a Dutch Telecom all's
every research and UCL have gone
together to make a mobile game to fight
dementia that's pretty cool
if you're not familiar with dementia one
of the first signs of it is loss of
navigational skills dementia steals your
memories and the times you had with the
people you love and it's just awful and
this game was made to conquer that so
the game is split up in different areas
and basically you're a sea explorer and
you need to navigate to recover your
lost than lost memories of your father
and you follow the same journey as he
Tek okay so here's where the game gets
interesting the data from people playing
this game and navigating around will be
analyzed by scientists and the more they
get the better results that we'll get
right now there's over four to nine
million people suffering from dementia
and no one has ever survived it there's
no cure and it's increasing there's
going to be 135 million people by the
year 2050
this games goal is to generate the
largest crowdsource global benchmark for
how people navigate so if hundred
thousand people play this game for two
minutes we can generate 58 years of lab
research gross check out this game I'm
going to donate $50,000 to Alexandra's
research as well please check out this
game in the description you it it's a
really cool thing and I think if all you
bros checked out this game download it
on your phone we can all help to support
research for dementia I think that's
[ __ ] awesome that is really cool and
I would love if you bros checked it out
tweet hashtag game for good with the
screen shot of you playing the game I
think that would be awesome now let's
get into some other games as well she's
they're all sheets one person plays the
game think for yourself find your
originality I'm so [ __ ] tired but
they even use the same [ __ ] thumbnail
I'm so tired of all these people just
copying it Jim it is copy anyway welcome
to life the game my name is Pam the most
original youtuber this is all part get
born okay
that is [ __ ] disgusting I'm sorry
okay well I failed at step one
well I tried original YouTube I couldn't
even get bored born there it is
talk I'm learning to speak
I still haven't seemed to be able to
master this art of shut up oh god it's
so fast-paced okay we learn how to study
study study drag-and-drop h2 no 12 plus
20s MA
[ __ ] you well I failed my grades I still
did fine
all right 17 320 okay the zits I got it
in my eye dude that's it is [ __ ] mess
I did it puberty no wait I never got a
single set all the ladies were like hey
that PewDiePie got I got we even got a
braces I never got braces I never got
zits I am 26
I still get these what the [ __ ] is wrong
with life after the pimple accident you
became the nipple face guy I am still
the nipple face guy okay I did it never
go on a date this has never happened in
my life
uh she looks boring you nope one of the
cutest girls it's your biggest regret of
your life try again oh I gotta be real
fast okay yes no yes yes yes it's a
match
okay what come on
I'm hitting so many balls dude okay I
can just do that I did it
Oh me coffee uh I miss I did it get
married [ __ ] I'll get married like this
listen if Mark said don't want me like
this she can have it not she can date
Edgar
alright finalize the trust I'll lie the
panties all right fine Jesus yay get
kids come on Matt yeah this is kind of
weird midlife crisis shopping list new
car dos please a new car weights we're
gonna travel now hey I got ripped at
least grandchildren drag and drop Oh
oh god she got sucked in with the
[ __ ] no don't no don't
Timmy you [ __ ] what is with kids I
hate any pie it sucks
yay stay healthy it's a bit too [ __ ]
short for that mate getting old [ __ ]
sucks I hope when I die at least I get
it on camera so Edgar can upload that
[ __ ] and cash in on it I did it
holy [ __ ] what No
loved by all that's hysterical
it's a very creative game I applaud very
well done but I'm moving on to the next
game I know what you're thinking are
these real or are they fake yeah well
guess what
only Marzia and edgar maybe we'll know
the true answer okay real or fake now
I'm done I consider myself a bit of a
connoisseur of real and fake I've done a
lot of Photoshop fakers and I think I
got a special eye for when it's real
I've seen a lot of fakes in my life and
I know what's real or not I can tell if
the photo is real or fake I will tell
you like it is I'm like the Kanye West's
of the YouTube except everyone hates me
anyway let's play this one all right so
real or fake now I'm gonna go with it
real Oh
what zing that it's a fake you can see
the shadow doesn't [ __ ] make any
sense go [ __ ] off that is so obviously
fake that fish looks as nothing let me
fix the image for you all right you got
to match the [ __ ] contrast like what
is this just so [ __ ] terrible
first let's blend it a little better
yeah that makes all the difference gotta
add a little bit of shadow take away the
pixels it's all in the details
now this is the type of photo that's
like so incredible that you're like when
I can be real all right so I'm gonna go
with the this is thick of course why
would a [ __ ] picture of an owl be
fake is the owl fake is the owl telling
us lies like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] [ __ ] why would this be fake it's
it's real right of course it's real
that eagle is so obviously photoshopped
what the [ __ ] why would there be a fake
picture of a baby
what the [ __ ] is is why would the church
be fake
well before what before they had a
couple that what the [ __ ] is this stupid
piece of [ __ ]
I've never been this pissed off in my
life [ __ ] you hey Bros thanks for
watching the video I forgot to do an
outro I am in New York right now so this
will be the outro please remember to
check out see heroquest I really
appreciate Bros it's for a good cost
it's in the description I will post my
donation on Twitter so you know it's
coming and that's it thanks for leaving
a like bros and as always stay awesome
you made me drop my [ __ ] bee